I don't know about you but the Amtrak
crash in Philadelphia has made me think
twice about getting on a train in the
u.s. the Train took a curve at twice the
speed it should have been going and
derailed killing eight and injuring
hundreds so what trains derail all the
time right well safety wise Amtrak lags
miserably behind most train systems in
developed countries and it pales in
comparison in terms of speed and
efficiency with high-speed rails around
the world train tickets are also pricey
sometimes double that of plane fares but
the demand for trains is still there
Amtrak ridership is increased in the
past decade to more than 30 million
riders a year so why then in the year
does train travel suck in the US the
first thing to know is that Amtrak the
u.s. is national passenger train company
is a private business that is owned and
funded by the government it was set up
in the 70s to support a struggling
passenger train network losing out to
cars and air travel but with one foot in
the public sphere and one foot in the
private Amtrak has neither been
profitable nor been given enough
government funding to be robust and it's
been accused of trying to reduce
expenses by lowering the quality and
quantity of services critics say
privatizing the company would push it to
offer better customer service others say
without government subsidies train
service might be worse though it's still
under investigation it's clear that the
Philadelphia crash could have been
prevented if there had been a safety
mechanism called positive train control
a technology that slows down trains to
avoid collision we feel that had such a
system been installed in this section of
track this accident would not have
occurred positive train control was
supposed to have been put into place by
the end of this year as Congress had
mandated back in 2008 but that hasn't
happened partly thanks to the railroad
into
so it claims positive train control is
too expensive and has been fighting
tooth and nail to prevent its
implementation through massive lobbying
in 2014 alone railroad groups spend
thirty four million dollars on lobbying
efforts and that's one them pull in
Congress
just hours after train 188 derail the
republican-dominated house voted to cut
Amtrak's budget by nearly 250 million
dollars about a fifth of its budget well
obviously it's not about funding
something that the train was going twice
the speed limit well it makes sense mr.
Boehner would say that he is one of the
top three congressional recipients of
railroad lobbying funds so has the
political drive to cut spending come at
the expense of safety all this begs the
question what are the u.s. is national
priorities spending on infrastructure is
the lowest it's been in 20 years and
that goes beyond trains to things like
bridges roads and airports spending that
isn't as flashy as say counterterrorism
but it's still important right
you